they're not calculating into the
equation the effects of lockdown
isolation masks school closes economic
effects and so on which I think were
years away from knowing what the full
effects so well that will be so far it
looks like it it has damaged our economy
and other things school kids are behind
and social attitudes about youngsters
and how they interact with each other
you know there's some studies coming out
now showing you know these kids just
coming into college now I have freshmen
myself you know they're very different
than they were a few years ago it's hard
to say what the cause is but social
isolation during covet might be one
you mentioned science before and as a
man of science and a man who likes facts
having been through two years of covet
and you are in California which I fled
because of covet and and lockdowns and
masks and injections you know mandated
injections all of these things that I
felt had nothing to do with science and
I think in or virtually nothing to do
with science or or a abusive science
let's say
um how how shaky do you think the
scientific world is right now I mean
fauci just in the last couple days
saying no I was never for lockdowns and
then it's like we're playing videos on
the show where he's calling for
lockdowns yeah a year ago and remember
what he said when you criticized me I am
the science you're criticizing the
science
yeah so that's it's been a problem for
the reputation of science I guess
because the CDC says one thing and then
changes his mind or fauci says you know
no mass the mass then no Mass but in a
way okay let's just step aside from
particular individuals like fauci and
just say in general if you don't know
what's going on and we didn't you know
you know it was a January 2020 the March
is when we were kind of uh realizing
okay there's something big Happening
Here what is it and it took a long time
to figure out what's the right thing to
do
there's so much uncertainty uh and so
much unpredictability in complex systems
like the human body of you know why do
some people get the virus who double vax
boosted they lead clean healthy lives
you know they're isolated Bast and they
get it anyway and I know people that
didn't do anything they didn't change
their life at all never wore a mask
never got and they get it nothing
happens right so it's like okay because
there's variation you know the body's a
complex system and people respond
differently and so it's these are on
average
recommendations and I try to be
sympathetic by putting myself in
somebody if I was a public policy person
if I was the head of a a Health
Institute or I was the mayor of the city
of La say or governor of California and
they stick a microphone in your face
they go okay what do we do
so here you have kind of a type one type
two error problem signal protection
problem if I say business as usual and
it turns out it's like Ebola or Aids
remember AIDS was 100 fatal uh at first
what if it turns out like that you know
and I really screwed up and it's on me
so they're more likely to err on the
other side like let's let's uh err on
the side of making a type one error
assume it's going to be terrible and if
it isn't well we got lucky of course
they're not calculating into the
equation the effects of lockdown
isolation masks school closes the
economic effects and so on which I think
we're years away from knowing what the
full effects so well that will be so far
it looks like it it has damaged our
economy and other things school kids are
behind and social attitudes about
youngsters and how they interact with
each other you know there's some studies
coming out now showing you know these
kids just coming into college now I have
freshmen myself you know they're very
different than they were a few years ago
hard to say what the cause is but social
isolation during covet might be one
anyway those are the kinds wait I'm
curious though how are you how are you
seeing that manifested in your students
now from say five years ago super quiet
very very reticent to say anything there
may be some there may be some cancel
culture effects there you know people
because I bring up abortion like we just
did an issue on abortion so you know
pro-life pro-choice all right kids let's
talk about it and they're you know
they're like uh uh
you know they're afraid to say anything
it's like how can you not have an
opinion uh and you're a Chapman which is
a great defender of research I mean one
of the few universities that is yeah so
here this is reflecting more of a
bottom-up kind of cultural shift I think
maybe they're just shy I don't know but
you know yesterday one of my student Ted
Talks was on uh attractiveness lookism
you know why is it that good-looking
people get more benefits than others
like all right you've got to have an
opinion on this right here's Brad Pitt
that's so unfair what are we gonna do
about Brad Pitt you know and they're
look like looking around like I don't
want to say anything I'm like oh come on
man so it could be some of that you know
we do know there's a uptick in uh
depression and cutting suicidal ideation
particularly among amongst girls you
know is it social media is it Facebook
is it social isolation during covet you
know we there's different factors we
don't know yet but something there are
some effects to that I'm curious how
much of this say related to kovid was
people that maybe weren't qualified or
in some ways were overqualified to give
information giving information so an
example I would use is right when the
the pandemic happened I had a bunch
bunch of experts on people that are
fairly well known and they were talking
about how to wash your bags when you
leave the grocery store and perfectly
you know put your mask on this way and
talking about social distancing a phrase
that no one had really uttered before
and all of these you know all of these
strange things had lockdowns which
really had never been done before at
scale and were based on basically some
wonky paper that never meant anything
but everyone just started saying the
same thing then when we find out it
doesn't work everyone just looks at the
the expert class and goes and I'm not
talking about the fauces or even the
cdc's I'm just talking about the general
people who are The Taste makers everyone
just looks at them and is like you guys
just screwed us all terribly that's
right right so whenever there's
uncertainty about the cause of something
let's say autism you know one reason
vaccines got associated with autism is
because we don't know the cause of
autism we still don't uh there's
probably multiple causes some genetic
predispositions who knows you know in in
the womb chemistry I don't know you know
we don't know but so that anything
that's even loosely associated then gets
Affiliated as a causal vector and I
think we see a lot of that in pandemics
like this where you just don't know
remember the when AIDS first came online
I mean there was like Panic oh you
shouldn't go in the swimming pool I
remember when Greg Louganis cut his head
on the diving board and Barbara Walters
was doing this private one-on-one
interview with him when he said it
talked about this he's oh my God Greg
you went in the pool right is that the
time it's like oh it could spread
through water with the air don't get on
a bus with an age patient you know it's
a gay disease all this crazy stuff it
was conspiracy theories about it the
black community that the CIA was up to
something uh with AIDS and you know but
these are not completely crazy this is
under my rubric of constructive
conspiracism yeah yeah you know because
the Tuskegee experiments where they you
know withheld treatments to African
Americans with syphilis and other
shenanigans that the CIA and the FBI I
have done to infiltrate black activist
groups to to Blackmail Martin Luther
King Jr and threatened if he doesn't
kill himself they're going to expose
they made sex tapes of him in hotel
rooms with women and so we're going to
play these publicly if you don't kill
yourself this is our government
did this so it's not completely crazy
for people who you know I don't trust
the government it's like yeah okay I
understand
so in essence by the end of reading this
most people will be a little more
libertarian perhaps
whereas you do go into several other
examples of that about how governments
have been doing this oh yes yes right MK
Ultra CA dosing citizen U.S citizens
with LSD just to see what would happen
they actually set up in brothels
um you know they had these Johns coming
and they would dose them with LSD and
then watch film them having sex with
prostitutes let's see what happens here
right it was all under this kind of
larger plan that you know you remember
the missile Gap well this was the the
Mind Control Gap you know the Chinese
and the Russians and the North Koreans
are ahead of us on mind control uh drugs
so we gotta do experiments on this so
again no Congressional approval people
didn't know about it president didn't
even know about it you know this is just
like Rogue uh factions in the in the
security State doing this so when people
talk about the Deep State there's people
behind the scenes doing things well
historically that has happened right
that's just MK Ultra that's just one if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about Academia
instead of nonstop stop yelling check
out our Academia playlist and if you
want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics check out our full
episode playlist they're all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell